you could sweat at any time really any
time you have to walk somewhere you're
warm upstairs maybe you're moist you
have to carry something to your Kings
sweat and coffee makes you sweat iced
coffee
makes you sweat if there's a strap on
you you're gonna sweat a little bit
extra right where that strap is and
sitting in a chair makes your back sweat
you'll avoid raising your arms because
doing so would reveal just how sweaty
you are you may have googled
hyperhidrosis and then wonder just how
sweaty does a person need to be in order
to having medical sweating condition
you've perfected the shirt fluff
technique to help air yourself out even
though it does nothing you've been asked
seriously hey is it raining out and
jokingly hey is it raining out that
second person sometimes you'll wear
layers to hide how sweaty you are but
that just makes you warmer and sweaty or
and eventually you have to take off that
layer and reveal that you're now the
sweatiest you've ever been and thinking
about how sweaty you are makes you
nervous about how sweaty you are which
just makes you sweat even more but it's
fine because everybody sweats just some
people are a little better at it than
others I guess